and i was like wait a minute sean so
you're telling me that there's a website
that you invest money in
you don't know who made it it doesn't
work a lot of the times and you can't
get the money out right and he's like
yeah i was like oh okay got it just
making sure we're on the same page
what's up uh sean here we have sam and
we got a guest his name is matter i'm
said it right because it's not a like
ladder but people know you as
diamond hands uh if they've been
following
we did a section on the podcast i don't
know how many months ago
where i was like hey there's this thing
that caught my eye it's called bitcloud
and
it's this crazy idea of a social network
where it's almost like a robin hood
meets twitter it's like everybody's got
their every profile every person has
their own coin and you can like invest
in people
and you can buy their coin and people's
prices can go up or down as they get
more famous
and um
i said you know there was a couple i
said i don't know if this is going to
work but i do hope that someday there's
a like a decentralized social network so
a social network that's not
you know super top-down controlled the
way facebook is the way twitter is
and um this is the first credible
attempt i had ever seen i had seen some
other experiments but this is the first
credible one where i said oh they have a
growth hack and the growth hack is that
when i saw my profile my profile was
already created for me it was a clone of
my twitter profile and i think it had
like sixty thousand dollars sitting in
the piggy bank and it just said claim it
verify your account like claim it and
that money's yours and i said oh that's
going to work people are going to
respond to that kind of incentive sam
did it too sam you had i don't know what
50 000 of your thing sam claimed it and
withdrew within a month or something
like that he bounced out of there but um
so people will remember big cloud you
were the creator of big cloud at the
time you were an anonymous account only
known as diamond hands now big cloud has
been renamed to diesel essentially
that's you know the new brand
and you've come out in the public and
now you're doing podcasts so that's
where we are welcome to the show big
cloud's awesome that's a great name i
love that name
uh yeah man i mean so just for context
sam and sean thanks for that awesome
intro man uh yeah i mean so since early
2019 i've been working really on a
blockchain that can power social social
networks uh you know not just bitcloud
but many other apps now they're actually
over 100 apps being built on the actual
blockchain itself which we call
decentralized social or dso uh and so uh
big cloud was actually just the first
app that really we launched on the
blockchain um and so kind of after
working on it for almost two years from
early 2019 we were like hey you know uh
now let's kind of put all the features
together that this blockchain can
support into some kind of product uh and
so that was bitcloud and it was really
just a prototype and it was intended to
kind of exercise and test uh a lot of
the functionality but the biggest one is
like the storage and the indexing of
posts which is a very hard problem for
for blockchains to solve and i don't
think anyone
other than diesel really has has had a
good solution to that um but uh but yeah
obviously we launched it so let me give
a little let me give a let me give a
layman layman explanation of this so sam
i don't know if you know this but um
there are actually a bunch of different
types of of blockchains because the apps
that you're building on top of them have
different needs so like you know bitcoin
has its blockchain and it's all it's
trying to do is you know really store
value be super secure it doesn't need to
be the fastest uh because bitcoin's not
about speed it's about security really
above all else and then ethereum was
like okay we're going to make a
blockchain that's more programmable it's
going to have maybe less security than
bitcoin because it's more programmable
but it's going to be able to do all
these other things and then like these
apps came out like on top of ethereum
that were like
crypto kitties and top shot which were
basically like the first kind of like
nft projects that got big and they
immediately like overwhelmed the
ethereum network and so the guys who
built uh nba top shot
when they uh you know they were the same
crew that built cryptokitties so when
they went out to build maybe a top shot
they actually made their own blockchain
called flow and flow was optimized for
the use case of
trading nfts and uh it can do higher
volumes so they all have different
tradeoffs and so what you're saying is
you made a blockchain that was good at
doing one thing which is social networks
are basically about posting photos and
videos and containing all that but today
if you go try to embed a photo and a
video on top of the bitcoin blockchain
or ethereum blockchain it would be
it's not
made for that and so it would be either
too big too slow two whatever just to
render one like news feed so you guys
built your own so is the name of the
blockchain diesel and the app is yeah
cloud is that idea and bitcoin by the
way sean it's really interesting it's
actually just one app there's actually
over a hundred now uh that are built on
top of it so you could like actually see
the same data
yeah you say that but like
does anybody use any of these apps like
you know i got 100 items on my desk
they're all worthless does anyone care
does anyone care about these hundred
apps on top of these
stuff like that yeah sean what's really
interesting is diamonddap.com is
actually more popular than bitcloud
already now um so i think it just passed
it even though it launched like a week
ago uh polygram.cc is the app that
people go to for nfts so actually when
people share dso nfts they actually
usually share links to polygram
not bitcloud
pulse is really good for
trading coins and clout feed is actually
a mobile app uh by the way cloudfeed i
think might already have more users than
bitcloud as well which is kind of crazy
um
okay i use cloudfeed uh because it's
because there's no mobile app right so i
think that's one of the challenges why
isn't there an app
because you're almost sort of playing
with one hand tied behind your back
twitter facebook they can send you push
notifications they're a normal app for
cloudfeed i had to like save something
to my ho i had to safely save a website
onto my home screen to make it look like
an app and but they still can't do push
notifications so is there a rule that's
that apple's blocking or google play is
blocking no well there are apps so
there's cloud feed and flick app is
actually another one uh that's actually
created by the former ceo of fanduel and
it's also very very popular but really
like sean you're touching on our
strategy which is we actually don't want
to build any products at all i didn't
even want to launch bitcloud ideally uh
i think that with this kind of next wave
of social i think what we're going to
see is kind of a separation of concerns
where you have this blockchain which is
the diesel blockchain that powers you
know kind of the back end of all these
things and then people who are much
better than me at building products
actually go out there and build them
right um and so for example if you look
at diamond app or you look at
polygram.you know again polygram.cc you
go to them and you're like whoa this
looks way better than that crappy
craigslist like thing that nader built
on you know which is bitcloud um and so
it's really the strategy for us to not
build anything and to let
we call it the app layer to be owned by
other people to give it away actually
so i think we should
i think we should do two things i think
we should explain why this matters
because to most people you're saying
like polygram and diamond app and it's
like these are things they've never
heard of and they should go check it out
but like i think i think it's more
important to just get have the idea
click in their head first which is
if i went to facebook let's say i was a
bad guy right
i go to facebook and i wanted to take
the most valuable thing i could take
yeah it wouldn't you know it wouldn't be
the engineers it wouldn't be the sign
out front it wouldn't be mark zuckerberg
i couldn't even mark zuckerberg is less
valuable than the one most important
thing it's basically the database right
so facebook would guard with its life
access to the database which is
basically a whole bunch of rows that
says sam parr here's his date of birth
here's his his profile picture here's
who he's friends with and that
information they keep under lock and key
and they give out little tidbits like
when they created a platform or you
could build a facebook app on top of
facebook or you can do login with
facebook they give you a little bit of
access because it's so valuable right
if i'm an app i don't want to make you
go through a full registration form and
upload a photo and then ask you to name
all your friends and add them if i could
just let you push one button and boom i
grab your facebook profile and your
facebook friends that was really
powerful idea but facebook obviously
keeps it under lock and key
and what's cool about it this is the
same way that like you know what's the
most valuable asset that the us
government has it's either the the guns
or the money it's one of the two but
let's just take the guns out for a
second the money right the right to to
sort of print the money and say we get
to collect taxes in this currency
therefore we have a monopoly on money
and bitcoin kind of broke that monopoly
in a way it said hey here's money
without the government if you like the
money part but you don't want the
government you can use bitcoin and what
you're kind of doing is the same idea
which is you're turning a social network
inside out the thing that facebook and
twitter would never do they would never
just give you account
root access to its database what you're
saying is here's a social network and
the database is fully open and available
to all if anybody wants to build any app
you can use this database it is fully
transparent and accessible that's the
main reason it exists and so you're kind
of taking a social network and you take
the thing they protect at its core and
you're turning it inside out you're
putting it right at the surface for
other people to use that's the big idea
for this stuff and what does that mean
that means
today if you don't people are
complaining about the facebook algorithm
right fake news or i don't like that
facebook censored donald trump or i
don't like that facebook did this well
your [__] out of luck you can't go use
facebook too you can't go use facebook
red which has a different algorithm but
with with this idea of dso that's what
could happen somebody could just make a
new app with a new algorithm that says
i'm only going to show pictures of hot
girls i'm only going to i'm not going to
censor anything or i'm gonna highlight
things that you you get to decide how
your feed is curated and so you could
build another
app that people could use without
starting all over from scratch so it
gives people choice i think that's the
big idea did i get it i made it i missed
it yeah and and maybe just to put like a
slightly different different take a way
of saying it is today you know facebook
twitter uh you know they're really about
monopolizing content like you said
keeping it under lock and key so that
they can show ads on it and if they
allow anyone else to build an app like
if they allow another company to build
an app on that monopolized content they
lose those eyeballs and they can't show
ads to them and it impacts their bottom
line so really the fact that their
business model is driven by ads is what
kind of forces them to say okay this
content's under lock and key we're the
only ones who can build apps on it we're
the only ones who can curate it and show
a feed uh and we can't let anyone else
uh aggregate eyeballs other than us
we're the only ones so really what deso
is about yeah right and
there's one other component you just
mentioned there which is the users the
people creating all the content
essentially doing all the work us the
dancing monkeys that go sit on twitter
all day coming up with interesting ideas
giving them the interesting content
we get zero right so like if i go check
my twitter ad split or my facebook ad
split and facebook made i don't know how
many tens of billions of dollars on ads
this year um but i get zero right and
and so that's the other component which
is their business model is we got to
keep all the eyeballs and then we want
to keep as much of the rev share as
possible um that's their their natural
kind of the game theory would lead them
to do that and with something like dso
you know i can make a post i can post on
there i go post on big clout and people
will literally i can make money off of
it basically if my post goes viral i
will actually benefit from the virality
from the value of my content and that's
the other if all this [__] works right
like forget the blockchain forget about
the how it works
if it works that's one thing that's
going to change that the creators who
make all the content will get a much
larger share of the revenue
what what do you think that share ends
up being is it more like
50 is it 90 10 is there is there even a
rev share like how much do you as the
maker of the diesel blockchain get yeah
well that's that's the funny thing is
that today the way facebook makes money
is with ads and like you said it doesn't
share very much of that with the
creators because when you have a
monopoly on something you know you can
be pretty greedy about it um and so deso
we're really all about opening up the
contents instead of monopolized content
it's open content so when you make a
post on bitcloud for example it actually
shows up in the in diamond app in
cloudfeed and all these other apps
because again the content is open it's
kind of like a utility rather than a
monopoly um and the question then if you
if you have all the content open is like
okay wait but like how does anyone make
money if all the contents open like
can't like show ads you know on uh you
know when all the content is open you
know that's why facebook is the way that
it is uh but um the interesting thing is
uh when you put all of the content on a
blockchain uh you actually get two
things you get openness you know that
you know all the content is open anyone
can build on it which we've been talking
about but you also get access to kind of
a new set of of features that involve
money in a very direct way um and so uh
you know for example right what you were
talking about earlier is the fact that
you know someone can have a coin
associated with their profile that
anyone can buy or sell right that was
that was one of the features that uh you
know the diesel blockchain supports that
feature is very difficult to do in a
centralized way uh both because kind of
the traditional financial system is very
kludgy so to have it for example b that
anyone in any country can like throw
tens of thousands of dollars around left
and right uh you know the traditional
financial system isn't really built for
that um and then um aside from that
right it's all open so people can
actually build on it and iterate and
create new experiences off of that same
that same kind of money feature set that
we haven't even thought of before um and
so going back to how does anyone make
money right the dso blockchain has a
native coin called dso right and so by
holding it similar to how anyone holds
bitcoin right as more usage comes on to
that blockchain the you know people the
demand for diesel should go up which
should cause the price to increase um
you know and then everyone who holds
diesel does very well um but aside from
that you know because that's how you
know i and anyone who's bought diesel
makes money um you know the creator can
basically keep the rest um and so there
might be small fees charged by the apps
that kind of enable the creator to do
like you know for example cloudfeed um
or diamond app might charge small fees
in order to earn an honest living and to
to make good money um and so i think we
might see uh you know basically um a
splitting of the market by a bunch of
different apps that kind of charge small
fees to allow the creators to do what
they do but that's competitive as
opposed to monopolistic and will
hopefully result in a lot more of the
value accruing to the creator as a
result so that's kind of the way to
think about it just a couple of kind of
quick questions because
um
sean is deeper in this world than i am
and i actually think that there's a few
more interesting stories here than just
the technology so how how many people
work there right now as full-time staff
yeah so uh we have about a dozen people
how much yeah
and
yeah and and what's funny is that team
we're now focusing mainly on the
blockchain and so but if you count all
the people who are working on apps you
know yeah but they probably got hundreds
of they're just using your right and and
totally so yeah only 12 people that's
crazy so you raised you raised funding
to do that yeah i think 100 million
dollars right
uh yes it's actually 5 000 bitcoin which
uh you know has appreciated a bit
and um yeah and you raise money so you
raise money but besides that money can
you tell me how much money has been
invested so darmash who we've had on
this pod i think i i don't i don't know
but if i had a guess i wouldn't be
surprised if you spent over a million
buying other people's coins uh roughly
i i think he said it publicly i think he
said it on on big cloud so how much
you're investing over a million dollars
can you tell me how much has been
invested on the platform
um yeah well so what's really cool is
because it's a blockchain it's open and
all of this data is open so you can go
for example to prospercloud.com
uh or you know i think bitcloudpulse.com
stats or like any of these websites and
they'll tell you i think right now
there's about 80 million dollars
invested in people's coins which to me
is absolutely
awesome i think we actually yeah
yeah yeah it is it's awesome um and all
that
does that count the money you guys
invested because when i showed up from
day one you guys did a smart growth hack
which you sort of pre-bought a bunch of
coins from naval and from jamaath and
from kim kardashian and whoever so you
kind of bought coins at a very low price
for all these so that their accounts had
some initial value which would attract
those people to come claim their
accounts so does that 80 million count
the money that you just bought i think
it does but i don't think it was very
much very many coins that we actually
put in um it was like maybe tens of
thousands of diesel you know that went
into it um so i'd have to look at
actually how much of it is that
appreciation of that but
um
yeah but there's definitely a piece of
work in that for the people wait let me
say one more thing
people are listening
we're looking at you now you're in a
dark room you have the shades pulled
down we had
biology on here um a while ago and he
had the same thing it was very dark and
he was like you know i don't and he said
on the pod he's like i don't really like
talking about my my location because
because he said i say some crazy i make
crazy predictions i'll speak out against
powerful people and i'm you know i don't
want to like take unnecessary risk and
let them know where i am are is this are
you in the same boat
yeah uh no no um i'm very open i'm in la
um you know i have a house here you have
security house uh i'm a very open person
um
well uh i don't know if you're supposed
to talk about your security because that
you know there's security dude
[Laughter]
let me ask this last question this is
the last time you guys had a question
i love it i love it so you you told me
you're 29. um i looked at your linkedin
you've had some like all your jobs have
been like fancy like high-end really
great jobs so but like compared to the
job that you have now they were normal
is working at big clout at all or uh d
so is it at all a normal like are you
gonna run this like a normal company or
are you gonna be um a little uh like if
you had to explain to your parents
like how your staff works and things
like that would it appear as though you
do have a normal a normal company or are
you doing some eccentric stuff that
would be intriguing
yeah well that's funny actually so uh
just to go into some eccentricities of
the project um you know that 5000
bitcoin i mentioned uh all that money
actually came in before there was any
corporate entities set up uh to do
anything um and so uh essentially the
way it worked was the blockchain was
running and if you sent bitcoin to this
treasury wallet uh the blockchain would
basically watch that treasury wallet and
give you diesel coins when it saw that
there was a deposit there to like a
corresponding key um and so it was all
automatic and so there were over 44 000
purchases and i don't even know
99 of like like them who they are
because they could just send bitcoin to
that thing and they would get diesel
coins on the diesel blockchain uh and
yeah we you know we didn't set up a
corporate entity um and that was you
know kind of two reasons there's a big
reason that we don't want people to rely
on it to feel like this is a centralized
thing that's going to own everything um
you know when you have equity holders
you know they're they have to kind of
fiduciary duty forces them to milk
everything and to be like hey like we
should close this down at some point and
really like make money off of it in like
a different way uh so that was that was
important um but uh but yeah and then
you know just just from a regulatory
standpoint you know um i i really you
know there was no issue or of anything
you know you just kind of threw bitcoin
in and got diesel back uh and so what
happened recently is and obviously that
made it very difficult to hire uh you
know that made it very difficult to even
talk about who we are um but very
recently you know the the platform has
you know the blockchain has kind of
gotten decentralized enough you know
where there are thousands of nodes
running running things uh there's like i
said like you know over 100 projects a
lot of them pretty legit and we felt
comfortable setting up a corporate
entity and kind of more normalizing how
we hire and stuff so now as of a couple
weeks ago there's the diesel foundation
um and so i'm on the board of it and i'm
i'm the only one right now but we're
hoping to basically bring on some really
legit people to join me and so it can
actually be this kind of well-governed
thing um and everyone's gonna work for
that entity um and so i think going
forward it will look very normal uh and
it'll kind of just be a you know an
organization that's a non-profit where
people are paid with cash and diesel
like a combination of the two uh and um
and we develop the blockchain and uh and
fund other people to build apps uh like
i said we're giving away the app layer
so that's kind of how we're thinking
about it
so
early on i remember the story was
uh nobody knows the creator but like i
heard kind of through back channels oh
we kind of know who it is because
because it seemed like you went out
fundraising because it was like hey this
is
should i send my bitcoin to this random
ass wallet and get back this coin back
that i don't know if i want if
and it was no no these are
yeah site barely worked it looked like a
virus um and then you know and it was
like no no there's so i texted some
people i said hey do you know what's
who's behind this is this legit they
said i think it's legit the guy behind
it's legit the people behind it have are
real builders
and they said uh you know andreessen and
social capital and like
a few tier one vcs have like are backing
it and so that gave people a lot of
comfort and that's why people like me
and others put in money i sent a hundred
thousand dollars into into big into into
big cloud or whatever to get it wasn't
even called diesel at the time i was
yeah different names something same kind
and um
and so uh so are you but you're saying
it now like oh i don't know these
strangers on the internet started
sending us bitcoin like definitely i'm
pretty sure you did some kind of road
show or somebody was doing something i
don't know i don't buy this dentist the
bridge there's two gaps
no no you're
way sharper and uh you're you're you're
you're playing us a little
no no no no i don't mean to play anyone
uh no totally just to give a little more
detail i love it i love it uh but yeah
just to give a little more detail um
yeah so what what's funny is uh you know
i worked on this on this blockchain for
almost two years since early 2019 and i
met a lot of investors through my last
company which was called basis you know
where i raised 140 million dollars and
then it didn't work uh wound up giving
you know deciding to kind of do what i
think is the right thing give all the
money back uh but so what happened with
diesel is i kind of worked on it for two
years you know alone by myself brought
on a couple of good friends uh and then
i talked to a bunch of the big names
that are now involved so like social
capital andreessen sequoia all of them
um and so what's funny about that is
that uh i you know obviously i i did i
talked to those people uh and so of the
44 000 purchases it's probably a few
hundred where you know i
kind of told them hey this is what it is
uh and so
um what's interesting about it is
but those were the big purchases right
so yeah they might be a few hundred but
they were yeah millions each i think uh
like you know so it might make up eighty
percent i think about 30 million dollars
worth uh was that um which is i think
not not a huge percent and no one has no
one owns more than five percent of the
supply from that uh so i actually think
you know i actually cared a lot about
keeping it very well distributed like
any good cryptocurrency but um uh but
yeah but all of them actually don't own
importantly they don't own equity in
anything uh all of their interest is in
the same asset that you or i hold which
is d so um some of them used corporate
entities to convert dollars to bitcoin
in order to do this weird thing uh but
they hold d so like those entities hold
d so for them uh and they'll like take
delivery like you know whenever they
want so
so that's cool and i think at the
beginning you had a bunch of things
sort of like we just retraced this story
right so you do basis you you have this
idea for a stable coin you end up giving
back the money when you decide it's not
going to work you um this new new idea
for for a decentralized social network
you raise some money from legit hitters
other people pile in like you're saying
it's all pretty quote unquote fair which
is that we're all owning the same thing
and um
and then you get to the point of the
launch you're you decide to be anonymous
you try to go the satoshi route um but
it doesn't work why didn't that why'd
you want to do that and why didn't that
work too many people yeah well so yeah
so basically you know been working on
this blockchain the diesel blockchain
for almost two years and uh we were like
hey you know we should really launch
kind of a prototype app to start testing
it like in the in the field so to speak
and that was bitcloud um and we wanted
to you know not really like have it go
mainstream until at least like the
middle of this year like the middle of
2021 um and so but you know we obviously
launching earlier is better and so we
kind of accelerated said okay in march
we're going to start sharing these like
password protected links with some
people just get a few hundred users kind
of see how the blockchain is holding up
with like this kind of activity uh and
so um
yeah so so what ended up happening was
uh it it you know kind of went out of
control and the links got like way over
shared um and to the point where i kind
of had to go out there uh you know i had
to start you know saying hey like this
is what this is and and this is like you
know what's going on uh but um
for me personally you know i've always
been
really
i think
i've always admired how like satoshi
kind of like launched bitcoin um without
creating kind of like a centralized
person that everyone kind of relies on
or like this is our you know our guy um
so it was really i wanted to kind of do
the same thing there uh and so i
launched with you know uh pseudonym
diamond hands um and immediately you
know it was kind of very hard to get
press it was hard to get people to kind
of listen to the story that that is the
real story versus making up their own uh
and so we had a lot of uh press saying
hey like this is a scam and by the way
because it was just a prototype there
were a lot of things were missing so you
couldn't cash out your money you
couldn't actually convert your money
and i was like wait a minute so you're
telling me that there's a website that
you invest money in
you don't know who made it it doesn't
work a lot of the times and you can't
get the money out right and he's like
yeah i was like oh okay got it just
making sure we're on the same page here
yeah right rightfully so uh any any
other time i would say that's a complete
scam
also none of the code was open so even
though it's a blockchain and it was
running on a few dozen nodes like no one
could actually audit it or be like hey
this is a real thing uh so we were just
not prepared at all let me let me tell
you something
there was a whole bunch of criticisms
like what you're talking about right the
code is not open source you can't cash
out oh they scraped our twitter profiles
um oh there's you know there's a big
pre-buy people got in super cheap uh you
know all this stuff there was all these
criticisms of it we don't know who the
founders are you know they're kind of
anonymous
but
my theory and you tell i wanna know what
you think about this so i have this
phrase which is i think emotion commits
the crime and then logic does the
cover-up so all these logical complaints
i don't think are the real reason why
people were so
like up in arms about this new project
that actually
is like a really net like it would if
something like this existed it would be
a huge net positive in the world and
those same people hate facebook well
this is the antidote if something like
this could actually get off the ground
and work and so um i was surprised that
the emotion was there and i think i at
least this is my theory
i think that people don't like when
someone gets rich without
quote unquote earning it and i think
what people saw
is that
the insiders so the people who created
it or maybe the early buyers they bought
so early on the bonding curve they got
so early on and wow 100 million dollars
has come into this thing these coins
have run up in price or the the profiles
have gone up in price and there was this
feeling like
like i don't know i don't know how well
you did but here's my guess i think
you've made
tens of millions of dollars already
liquid without uh at the minimum
and your project is like
under 10 000 dau or something like that
right so uh or under 50 000 let's say so
like in already in the tech world this
tech gets backlash because people will
raise at like 100 million valuation and
people are like oh i've been running
this restaurant and laundromat for years
and how does this little app with you
know with with no business model be
worth 100 million dollars right there's
already people who get upset about that
but but the one saving grace is that
they're not liquid so it's not like the
founders running around in a lambo just
living in a mansion in l.a but in crypto
you're liquid too so you you get the
early hype and you get the liquidity of
the lambo and the mansion and i think
that that is actually what triggers
people about crypto in general bitcoin
in general you know people who buy an
nft and they get rich you know they make
a million dollars off this random image
um to i think to other people that feels
inherently unfair
and so do you what do you think is my
theory what do you think of my theory
and then what's your kind of response to
the people who do feel that way i think
there must be some like validity to your
theory because if you read there's a
great book called the infinite machine
about ethereum and it catalogs like what
happened ethereum how it launched all
this stuff they got major backlash from
bitcoin people because of the way they
raised money where they were like hey
like you know projects aren't supposed
to like take bitcoin for you know
another [__] coin like you know this is
like bad
i mean i read that book right after you
know kind of everything that was
happening with bitcloud and i was like
this is
eerily similar
um so so i think part of part of what
you're saying has to be part like like a
factor um you know dude look that said
you know since then diesel is listed on
exchanges you can trade it on
blockchain.com ascendex and a really big
one you know a couple big ones are
coming soon and you know like the code
is all open and people have gotten
really passionate about it um you know
contributing to it the last couple
people we've hired are like open source
like they were just contributing to and
we hired them so i think that um you
know if i saw someone who's
very clearly a scammer
making lots of money i would be upset in
a way that i would be i wouldn't be as
upset if i felt like there was a shred
of them not being a scammer which we
didn't have because i was anonymous you
couldn't cash out the app was going down
a lot um
so uh whatever whatever theory there is
is probably exacerbated can i give you
some feedback and it's like it's a
compliment i i when you first launched i
was like diamond hands like when i think
of diamond hands i think of finance bros
and um i you know when i think of
this anonymous thing i was like i
actually i'm not on board with this
although i agree i think it was wise for
you to launch anonymously i actually
think it's wonderful that you're coming
out because your personality even though
we've only known each other for 45
minutes now your personality
guy for some you have a very trusting
you you give off trustworthy vibes and i
actually think it's it's you've done the
right move by coming out and and
discussing things um i actually it makes
me like big clout more before the way
that it looked and the diamond hand's
name i was like i don't know if i uh if
this if this screams trust but you i i
think it's good to have like what what's
the uh like i'm a pretty big new but
what's the founder of ethereum
how do you say
yeah so i thought
i watched a lot of his interviews
screams trustworthy like i i i i like i
buy what he's saying i'm like oh you're
like he's really young but he's way wise
beyond his ears
he says a lot of intelligent things that
i agree with he seems good-natured you
have a very similar quality so i think
it's smart that you're doing it
and let's not lie sam vitalik looks like
a boy genius like uber nerd and we're
like oh let's invest in this this guy is
probably going to make it matter but
that you know
you're the perfect mix of like
intelligent nerd but you also like look
pretty slick you're good-looking
yeah you're smooth you you've got a good
you've got your personal uh anyway it's
so this is a compliment i think it's
good that you're doing what you're doing
you're too kind man i appreciate it
let's do let's do one one like thought
exercise because i think most people
still aren't going to really fully
understand okay if a social network oh
decentralized blah blah blah so let's
take about let's think about it from the
perspective of the user who doesn't care
if a database runs on sql or the
blockchain and um who you know
they're going to use something because
it provides some new value to them right
so even the idea of like
it not being a monopoly like i think
most people are inherently fairly lazy
and they they're probably gonna just go
with a default app anyways uh you know
for a social network even if there was
more choice so let's just take the
actual like fun bit so
um
on big clout there was this idea that
every creator every user had a coin and
so i had a coin and i you know you give
me a number i want it to go up i'm i'm
like a monkey i'll immediately start
playing whatever game is required for
that number to go up and so my coin
started at a certain price i remember it
at its peak it was like five thousand
dollars a coin my market cap was like
half a million dollars i was on top of
the world and now i stopped using it
it's crashed i'm down 4x and all this
good stuff but what is the aside from
the you know pure gambling side of
speculation and just the joy of seeing
money go up whether as a holder or the
owner of the coin
what is the actual purpose why should
individuals on a social network have
their own coin what would you do with
that why is that a good idea and just
walk through like a use case so no
theory but like here's jo here's guys
here's why sam would want this and why
that's good like the idiot of this
podcast i'll take it
he was like sam so do you know that
there's different blockchains
yeah go ahead matter i'll let you i'll
i'll let you leader of that no i do talk
talk to me like i'm fine
totally uh well like yeah i mean look
it's a great question i mean so um
there's a deeper story to uh you know
and so by the way the diesel blockchain
supports all kinds of money stuff right
not just coins but also nfts and
diamonds which are like tips uh and
people can build other things too but
the the coins having a coin associated
with your profile is kind of what i
think to be
kind of you know this this wave was
about nfts i think the next wave is
going to be about creator coins also
known as social tokens um and the reason
why
i got really excited about them as a as
like kind of an asset class uh is
actually a cash flow story so
essentially um you know with with dso
right uh when you use any app right to
access diesel uh you can do a lot of the
same things you do on a traditional
social network like you can post uh and
you know all that kind of stuff um but
you know you can also do stuff with
money and you have new ways to monetize
uh that kind of arise and so
what's interesting is that um
essentially you can have creators making
money through these other features and
then take a percentage of that cash flow
and send it back to that creator's coin
holders as a dividend long term um and
so just to give an example right today
when you sell an nft on any diesel app
you know like polygram or diamond um you
can actually set a percentage that's
like what we call a creator coin a coin
holder royalty uh and so every time that
nft resells a percentage of that sale
goes back to the coin holders um and so
i think that essentially the coins if
you if you play this out right uh and
you have like for example promoted posts
where someone can give you you can have
an inbox of posts that people pay you to
like repost your followers and and a
percentage of that can go to the coin
holders um you know you kind of have all
of these new kind of like money native
you know blockchain native business
models for creators making money and if
you allow a percentage of that to flow
to the coins then suddenly it's kind of
like you unbundled the equity of a
company like facebook into like each
creator's coin and therefore the fans or
or the holders of that creator and so to
me the coins are exciting as a means
long term of like democratizing
kind of like the cash flows of a social
network into the fans of a particular
creator and if you play all of that out
suddenly it makes it a lot easier for
really awesome smaller creators to get
discovered right because when you create
that that kind of loop of like oh if
they become big cash flows will flow to
their coin from their monetization on
the platform right and those cash flows
will be big if they're popular suddenly
you want to back the smaller creator who
you recognize is awesome but that nobody
else really knows about um and so to me
kind of democratizing the ownership of a
social media platform is like what the
coins are about and creating that
incentive for smaller creators to get
discovered get invested and have people
kind of grow with them um
is the kind of the long term of it but
obviously it's early so a lot of people
don't what's it gonna be thinking about
that look like in five or ten years how
is this going to be what do you think
your business will be like
yeah i mean so even in a couple of years
you know i mean you know let's say we
have like you know 10 million daily
active users right um there are a lot of
ways that we can build monetization for
creators into the blockchain nfts are
already there and creators have made
hundreds of thousands of dollars off of
that like tens of thousands i think for
one of them they had over a hundred
thousand dollars flow to their coin
already through the cr crater coin
royalties uh but there are other
features too you know like for example
that like that pay to promote uh or pay
to repost kind of mechanism where an
advertiser can say hey repost this to
your fans i'll give you this amount of
money uh and then a percentage of that
can flow to the coins so basically any
way new ways that we create for creators
to monetize on the platform a percentage
of that can flow to the coins and
suddenly the coins kind of become not
just about pure speculation but about
hey like what what kind of cash flows is
this creator gonna do um and that it's
gonna be a lot because not not just
because you know the platform is is more
efficient you know like i i do think you
know things like nfts things like you
know paid repost can be more efficient
than the traditional model today where
we have kind of a centralized company
just showing random ads uh but um yeah
but but also just because uh there are
so many more things that you can do
right that could you know earn cash
flows that end up going to the coin that
we haven't even thought about yet
so you did the thing that i was hoping
you wouldn't do which is you you did
some theory uh so so you know anytime
this is the tell in the tech world
anytime somebody starts talking about
democratizing democratizing it's the new
it's just a smart guy way of
true i can't stand that word
yeah exactly uh you know you want your
company to be disruptive and
democratizing at the same time right and
also if they say there's a new asset
class they're probably it's probably a
good idea but they're giving you kind of
like the grandiose steve jobs vision um
actually i shouldn't say steve jobs
because steve jobs was great at
basically saying a thousand songs in
your pocket and like just leading with
the killer hook and and i think for
for this you know what i was hoping you
would say
and so i'm going to kind of say it here
is
i don't know if you know this but sam is
an aspiring fitness influencer a rising
fitness influencer and so those who are
yeah rising i should say not aspiring
he's he's aspired um
yeah
oh perfect i got my two
you want to play oh you're over here
yeah dude bitcoin
might not guy next door your niche could
it could be like like love it
i'll be like the nerd who you know
started really frail and then made his
way there's definitely a need
and so you know someone like saying
basically i i know sam i say this guy
and i see his videos i'm like oh these
these are great videos he's only getting
you know a couple thousand views let's
say right now but i i basically what
what this world would let me do is as an
early believer i can bet on sam i could
say i like this guy's content i think
this guy's gonna blow up and i can kind
of vote for his success i can give him
some so i can buy his coin which gives
him money to like make better content it
gives him a little boost of morale to
keep going
but it also lets me go on the ride with
him because i think we've all been there
before we discover a band early or a
brand early or an influencer early and
then you're you're you believe in them
and you're so you're so right they
actually do take off they never knew you
they never had a real relationship with
you and you didn't benefit from the fact
that you know kim carter if you knew kim
kardashian back when she was just paris
hilton's closet organizer uh and you
thought she was great you missed out on
the ride and and so this lets your true
fans go on the ride with you and it
turns your fans into sort of
shareholders with you and so
oh bro i study this stuff you know kim
kardashian where did this come from i
have to know i must know and uh and sure
enough there's a story and so you know
sam let's say i would bet on sam sam
would get that cash so sam could use
that to make a cooler video and when sam
makes that video and he gets more
followers
they have to buy in at a higher price
point than i did because now sam's more
established so my stock is going up i'm
earning instead of just following right
i own instead of just following which is
the way the world works today with
twitter and instagram you just follow
you don't earn and then this the you
know furthermore sam could say hey you
know what how do i make my coin really
valuable to hold what if i kind of only
fans it and i said i'm going to do some
exclusive stuff with only my coin
holders who hold over 100 of my coin so
it's up to him to decide if he wants to
make his coin more juicy more more
enticing to hold which again will make
my stock go up if i know sam's the kind
of guy he connects with his fans he's
going to put in the effort that's going
to make these coins more valuable and so
it takes this idea that's been around
for a long time the thousand true fans
the thing that any artist knows that
they need those real believers and it
turns them into people who actually
benefit from your rise and so that's
what i think that's the good thing that
i think will come of this aside from you
know destroying facebook and all that
good stuff i think the good thing that
will come of this it'll make being a
taste maker and a curator
like a job pretty much you can actually
get paid for having good taste for
following for believing in somebody
early on which is the way that things
should be i think yeah sean how are you
better at explaining this than me also i
i i'm kind of uh
i'm not offended but uh that's awesome
well dude when i first shouted out big
clowns
okay i gotta come up with a reason that
i like this besides i think this is
gonna make a lot of money for me uh so i
started thinking about what what is the
appeal here and i have to defend myself
and in doing something with the case
yeah
that's true i did i i remember it uh but
yeah sean just to add which is really
interesting uh like you said there's
actually never been a way to actually
invest in someone when they're small and
make money on their rise like in like
this easily this efficiently uh and
what's really interesting is there's
actually yet another interesting kind of
like layer on it which is once you
invest in someone your bias is to be
supportive your bias is actually to be
hey i want this guy to succeed i want
this person to to be something and you
can align in a way that you can't really
on like you know without that mechanism
like being able to buy into someone you
know uh uh creates kind of an incentive
that doesn't exist and what's crazy is
that um even bitcloud you know bitcloud
diamond all these apps uh they're
actually very positive discourse a lot
of it um even though you know there's
not really any kind of you know there's
not like there's less moderation than
traditional social media right um and
the reason i think is basically you're
investing in people right you're going
long uh and and when you give people the
ability to to like move money around
right people naturally go long and when
they go long they actually uh uh get
aligned and want to support you um and
so weirdly enough like
i love like when people say like money
is like the root of all evil you know
like money is bad and and i think that's
part of why people reacted weirdly to
bitcloud because like oh money prices
whatever but like if you just look past
that for two seconds you'll see that
it's actually being used as an alignment
tool that's making
a lot of positive things happen that
haven't happened what are your um let me
let me ask you a couple personal
questions real quick what do your
parents do for a living
yeah so uh my dad is an engineer and my
mom is a social worker
yeah so my mom was in virginia where i
grew up for a long time she actually
moved to san francisco uh uh my dad
passed away a few years ago but i'm
looking at your linkedin you you
you've always been a freak you went to
princeton you know you you've all you
studied computer science and applied
math at princeton you work
yeah it's a compliment that's a
compliment you worked at
the famous for uh being high frequency
trading but also that's like that's
where i think jeff bezos worked and uh
the founder i forget his name shaw is it
just shaw uh
david shaw david shaw he's you know a
wizard you work you went to google at uh
and you're a software engineer there and
then you raised 125 million dollars for
a startup which is
crazy or 133 million you you you said on
this blog post you gave the money back
because you know it didn't work out so
well what are your what does your mom
think about like when you're trying to
explain to your mom who's a social
worker my mom's a teacher so she doesn't
you know and i'm in tech too when you're
explaining to your mom what you do for a
living or your aunts and uncles or your
brother and sister friends who aren't
you know like you
what do they think about this the fact
that a 29 year old although you know
you're 25 it looks like when you raise
133 million
are they like
what do they think of this life that you
have
yeah i mean so my mom watches every
single video that comes out she's gonna
watch this and she's gonna call me about
it and and tell me all her thoughts uh
so so there's that uh but yeah man i
mean i just you know i live modest life
you know i i don't think anything really
has changed for me personally and like
look you know to your point and to
sean's point earlier you know on like oh
someone made so much money without like
having produced something right um you
know i'm very serious about just
mentally i don't think of myself as
having any money right until we've
really made it like you know i'm talking
millions of users people really getting
value at a large scale right uh so to me
it's very important to not think about
oh i'm i've made it when you know like
like we have a lot to do like left to do
um and so yeah and by the way you know
funny funny fact uh with basis uh my
last company where i raised 140 million
and returned it um i actually had less
money after that in in my bank account
than when i started it which is
basically about three years of runway
from my like google analytics
no i'm very lucky just because you know
i mean i had you know like three years
of runway like you know maybe like a few
hundred k or whatever uh and um i'm very
lucky to have had that uh because if i
didn't have that i would have had to go
back immediately to working at google
which
oh my god that's so bad it's the best
company in the world i'm very lucky
right but um but yeah my like it's funny
like i've been through like very high
highs and like well the lows aren't very
low because i'm very lucky obviously but
uh but yeah after basis i was like i'm
gonna try and do something else that's
really impactful like not in the context
of working at a company and if i can
find something before i run out of money
that's great but if not i'm going to go
enjoy my life at google which i love you
know i really love being an engineer at
google yeah i like to talk about human
[__] and you're i have a feeling that
this i was not you heard the last
podcast i was the i was the hater of the
two of of big clout my opinion is likely
changed as of now
because of how
you know sean's like this uh my good
friend neville is like this you're
incredibly emotionally stable and
because of that i actually think that
that could make uh this business
incredibly successful
well i mean i appreciate it man i mean
yeah i mean i think that uh yeah i mean
i think it's just really important to
keep perspective right you know i mean
and also like you know sam just to
emphasize
you know i'm really lucky so it's not
like it's a lot easier for me to be
emotionally stable i feel than like
someone who's actually had it pretty
hard you know and i think genetic yeah i
think it's genetic and i think it's
upbringing
i think if you're if you're surrounded
by love when you're when you're growing
up and for some genetic stuff you're
just going to be like pretty stable it's
i just like now i understand now i want
to buy your coin on big cloud
oh nice oh i'm i that is like the
biggest compliment you can give me this
entire podcast
i actually own some sean already but i i
don't know sam if i found what's your
handle on on uh on diamond or
that's uh so i don't know if you made it
i haven't logged in
i have it like we'll find it after this
yeah yeah i think you've converted me
now i like i said i i don't think i was
completely a complete hater but of the
two i was the the more of the hater for
sure sean was like
i i probably made fun of sean cause he
was like this is the greatest thing ever
uh and and and we'll see who's right but
i i i you convinced me
well
i i think
i i kind of i don't know if i fully said
this the first time but basically i
think that whoever can
can break through and create a
decentralized social network no social
network will that'll be one of the most
important changes in the world over the
next 20 years like self-driving cars i
think is going to save a bunch of lives
i think ai is going to introduce a lot
of like productivity gains and like you
know kind of cause some labor like
changes in the way that labor works
and i think that whoever can take social
networking and make it an open uh do it
the crypto way with the crypto values i
think that that
person or that group of people is going
to have done a lot of great in the world
and i think it's going to be a huge
project i think it is going to be a
multi-trillion dollar project when it
whenever it works and i think i said
this early on which is i don't i'm not
saying that this one will work i think
there's still probably a sub five
percent chance that this works
and i said but if it works the payoff is
huge so i that's the type of bet you
make in the tech world low probability
high payoff and when you when you go at
it with an enthusiasm you're gonna learn
about it and you're gonna go for that
ride with a bunch of early adopters and
even if it crashes and it doesn't end up
working out we're gonna all have learned
a bunch of lessons so that when the
right one does come around you say ah
that one makes sense this solves the
problems of the last one or this feels
different and so i know that this is the
real one but you never know unless you
go in with you know sort of a belief
mentality towards these things because
it's easy to just say this is not going
to work and you'll be right on 99 out of
100 times it's just that the one that
100 matters you'll have also said it's
never going to work and you wrote it off
and therefore you didn't benefit from it
in any way that's like you know optimism
pays in the tech world and so even
though i got a lot of [__] you got 10
000 times more [__] for for doing the
project um i just feel like that's such
a misguided way of living and like you
know again optimism is in this business
so i find skepticism is useful at
certain
points but you know you want to default
to optimism and then go in and find the
things that don't smell quite right and
uh but but you know
even then you'll just have learned a
bunch and gotten a bunch of experience
and played with all the new things so
that you know when the real one is huge
and and yeah and i think it's really
awesome that you know for me you know i
get to do the thing that i love in the
world which is to build cool [__] and uh
and and that's helpful to people and
even though like you said like five
percent you know and and you can do that
and and it actually is something that uh
you know at least the expected value can
help but um give us
give us the uh the craziest story cause
i remember i was on big cloud and it's
like oh pamela anderson joins and she's
a huge fan and then like i don't know
whoever it was all kinds of crazy
characters you know that were joining
this thing i was like i haven't thought
about pamela anderson in like 20 years
uh this is amazing and she's like you
know good creating all these incentives
for her coin holders
you on the inside every day you must
have just been seeing all the random
stuff and getting threats from one side
and praise from these random people give
us a give us a war story or a crazy
story that like
is just kind of fun uh that that yeah
totally um
yeah i mean what's interesting is that
it did attract a lot of like pretty
famous people to like join or create
profiles you know i think like diplo and
blau tyga antonio brown are still like
posting there and stuff uh but um i
think probably the craziest story is uh
at some point i went to a dinner uh in
l.a
and
i don't know if i'm like even allowed to
say but there were like a lot of famous
people there and i got to kind of like
tell them about it
uh
give cat give
how do i even
uh there were billionaire tech ceos and
then also uh the biggest celebrity like
someone's name who sean mentioned
earlier uh who was a clotted closet
organizer okay uh
yeah
all of them
yeah and so i think um yeah just being
able to kind of explain our vision to
all these people was really awesome uh
and uh and yeah and i think what's cool
is like you know when you really get to
explain it everyone gets excited about
it even even in spite of kind of all the
initial like oh you can't cash out or
like this and that like when you're like
hey like this is what it is um it's
inspiring and like you said sean uh if
we can actually
use these features these new kind of
like money features like the coins like
the nfts like the diamonds all that
stuff to decentralize social media it's
going to do a lot of good you know um
independent of the fact that they make
creators more money and align with fans
a high schooler in virginia that you'd
be a
crypto nerd hanging out in l.a at a
mansion dinner with kim kardashian
i mean what's funny about it is uh i was
really into bitcoin in college in like
2013. uh so i built a minor i met mark
carpalas as the ceo of mount gox uh my
friend and i like went to japan and
randomly tweeted him and he was like
come by our office i met him so i was
really into like bitcoin and crypto uh
and you know when bitcoin crashed i was
like okay i guess i'm gonna go do my
hedge fund thing or whatever uh but it's
funny i think if you told like college
natter that like this is what he'd be
doing i think he'd be like
yeah that's awesome you know that's
that's cool
that's about right
the kim kardashian part like you know
maybe not no i mean
um
yeah i'm gonna it's like i'm asking you
stock tips i'm on big cloud uh i'm on
the site now what uh
and i could see this i mean i could just
go and find it but what what creators do
you own and what what uh what which one
are you gonna be making any purchases
anytime soon what do you like
yeah definitely i own active creators so
if a creator is active and like posting
and like doing fun stuff or interesting
stuff i buy them um but really the thing
that i uh you know like the hedge fund
side of me really likes is nft artists
because for nft artists uh even today
not theoretical um all of them set
royalties that go to their coins um and
so there's real cash flows there that
are often like totally disparate like
you know like their coins are not like
correctly priced for like how much money
is gonna actually flow to their coins um
and so i've been yeah i bought like
spookies and um
uh clout punk you know early illuminati
is like another one um and those like
just the cash flows are like above what
it was when i like you know those have
made up for what it was when i invested
in it so uh so that's kind of like i
think that's a strategy that like just
traditional like i do like i get it um
and then as we create more cash flows
going to the coins there'll be even more
um but aside from that because i know
that you know creators who could get big
are going to have ways that cash flows
go to the coins the smaller creators who
i think are active and are like gonna do
cool [__] anyone in particular you know
that's who you enjoy that's like the
other one
um oh there are a bunch um well so
darmesh has been crushing it he's not a
smaller creator uh but he's just been
super active he's been doing a lot of
stuff creating time right now
yeah yeah yeah he's he's he's very big
on the platform um i'm trying to see
like there's like matreshka who's a
woman who's very active there and does a
lot of stuff tidgeon is this developer
who does a lot of awesome stuff
um yeah it's aditya you want to know my
strategy that that worked on big clout
at least early on this worked pretty
well i i was thinking about okay who do
i buy do i buy the famous people that
are not on yet there's people building
scrapers to try to figure out someone's
thinking about it or they tweeted it out
and it hasn't gotten verified yet so go
front run that
i figured out there's a very simple way
to win and i said
right now with any early project i've
built a bunch of social networks and i
know anytime you build a social network
at first 70 of the conversation on that
social network is about the social
network this happened with the stuff i
built it happens if you go to clubhouse
eighty percent of the rooms are just end
up they will end up talking about how
great clubhouse is or what it's gonna be
or what's bad about it they're just
always talking about the platform itself
so i knew okay if people are gonna be
interested in the platform itself i
invested in all of the analysts who
could who could go through the on-chain
data and report how what prices were
working you know how many how many new
users there were and all that good stuff
and so i bought all the analysts dirt
cheap and they went up like crazy
because again they were talking about
the platform in a way that was
differentiated because the normal person
didn't know how to go analyze the
blockchain and then the other one was
basically rich active people so i saw
darmesh was just gonna buy his own coin
and whale shark was just gonna buy his
own coin craig clemons was gonna buy his
own coin and so it's like a company that
does a share buyback
it's like oh okay this person has the
they have enough funds where they could
like dramatically move their own coin
price so all i got to do is just buy
them and wait for them to do their
buybacks and sure enough they did and
dartmouth even said it publicly it's
like i'm gonna buy for every follower i
get i'm gonna buy back my every every
coin holder i get i'm gonna buy back 10x
of my own coin or something crazy like
that and i was like well that's a ponzi
scheme that i love that's perfect great
uh like i'll just hitch onto that ride
this guy's guaranteeing and i know he's
a man of his word he's gonna buy he's
gonna buy back his own stuff and i could
just front run that so that worked
amazingly at the beginning i don't know
if that would still work now the
strategy of forecasting what content is
gonna be popular and then investing in
the people who are producing it i mean
that's like that's like the name of the
game i think um so i think that's pretty
awesome uh yeah
like there was a guy who would do uh
fake designs like mock-ups like oh this
is what the client could look like yeah
oh if they add it in it's how it
it's just like kind of like design porn
yeah design porn i was like oh that's
going to work people are again it's
talking about the platform and in a
differentiated way because this guy's a
designer and he's going to just design
mockups all the time this is going to go
viral great yeah no that's genius
honestly um yeah and it'll be
interesting to see how it works at scale
um especially because diamond app is
like so mainstream and i think can
actually get like some bigger people to
like join and start using it um
yeah i honestly i wonder how it's gonna
play out um by the way another fun thing
we didn't talk about is there's actually
an algorithmic feed that's like open
source now built into the blockchain so
that would probably play into your
strategy where you can look at how the
feed works and then try and figure out
what what's gonna get to the top
it's pretty hard to game i think but uh
but that's that's another like
interesting have you talked to their
master so for the people saying dartmesh
is one of the co-founders of hubspot as
of today he's probably worth just off
hubspot stock it's public you can go and
look probably like a billion and a half
so very very very successful
he was part of big clout very early i
mean he was telling us very early on
that he was buying a lot and he's he
wasn't an angel investor but he was an
early investor in coinbase he was an
early investor in crypto he obviously
has hubspot wildly successful and he's
like this is my thing so have you have
you hung out with him he that guy is
interesting as hell
well what's crazy is i think i met
darmesh like pretty late in the game i
had like a pretty short call with him
where i just kind of we just talked
about you know life what the thing is
and what bitcloud and diesel is and all
that stuff um so what's funny is i think
darmesh just like really independently
kind of saw whoa you know like you know
if like you said sean you know in the
five percent where it works or whatever
like this is huge uh
and um so what's funny yeah i i've had a
very short conversation with him i'd
love to to hang out with him more but uh
you know he's busy and uh obviously we
have lots of business
i honestly think
you know
he does post a lot i think 99 of people
um
they'll say they're not doing it for the
money and then they totally are he's
like the one person i believe that is
not actually doing it for the money so i
i genuinely believe he's doing it
because he's like i want this to win and
in order for this to win we need like
economic activity we need like positive
energy in the system so i'm gonna
literally like almost in a philanthropic
way put a bunch of money in to just like
get kick-start this because it's gonna
take some enough people doing that
because like i said right now it's small
it's really small and like that you know
there's the
with crypto there's these hype cycles at
the beginning but there's a vicious
other side which is that if it doesn't
just keep magically going up people get
disillusioned for a bit and then it has
to get another
thing that like picks it up and so um i
think he was genuinely just trying to
you know kickstart activity and
enthusiasm totally and i mean another
thing to your point sean uh i i have you
know good news to you for you like with
regard to if we can do like a social
media you know decentralized social it's
going to be really awesome which is that
um i actually think
i won't say the word it's inevitable but
i think it's actually very asymmetric
like in favor of decentralized platforms
actually winning um the main reason
being that i think when all the content
is open and anyone can build on it i
think that the speed of iteration that
you can have and the like caliber of
product is just a lot higher um so you
know just like you know on that five
percent you know it's like
if you know for example just because all
the content is open right we can have
like all this over 100 teams that like
we didn't even hire just go out there
and build way better apps than we were
capable of building internally but then
it's even bigger which is like you get
like once you get a little bit bigger
you know let's see if like a million
users now you have like traditional
publishers basically looking at the open
content being like hey like with one
engineer we could spin up like a sp a
feed like espn or something can spin up
a sports feed for sports influencers
right and be like hey like this is cheap
like we should do this and get into the
social game and make marginal money um
and then you know in other countries
this is i think something that darmesh
really likes uh you know for example in
a country like india or russia or
something like that uh today they use
twitter a lot they use they use
basically apps built predominantly by
people in silicon valley uh and the
reason is that you know silicon valley
has a monopoly on the content and you
know they because they have that you
have to use their apps but when all the
content is open you can actually have
people in the native country build the
apps that you use and tailor it to their
uh to their user base um you can read
stories about how facebook was just
horrible in japan for a really long time
and like nobody you know they had to
make all these optimizations that were
like kludgy uh to to you know they were
just leaving on the ground like no one
was doing them because they're
centralized kind of centrally planned
organization so i think once you have a
blockchain that can actually handle
posts and data which hasn't really has
not existed until do so um i i think it
just kind of opens the floodgates for
this
like number of innovators and an amount
of energy that wants to build that
is
it just has to beat your essential plan
model like i just don't you've got to
get the power
i know that like i i it always works
this way you make a big splash
um and then there's like either down it
goes down or it plateaus and then it
needs to go up right now you guys had
that massive splash
it went away for a minute because as it
does everything novelty always goes it
goes away and then you got you're gonna
have your comeback up and so i hope that
you could pull this off and you have to
make it so like i want to go there and
all of us want to go there on a
consistent basis because if you can't
pull that off you're not dick and i want
you to kick ass
totally and i have a funny story for you
actually uh so i think on that the
crypto side of things helps us a lot uh
because crypto
it's really hard to kill something
that's crypto i've i've learned uh and
so just to give you an example uh
cryptokitties was this nft project that
got really really big and then died or
whatever right and what's funny is
during the cryptokitties hype i gave a
talk about my project different it's
like a stable coin uh but
the co-founder of openc xander tala was
at the talk he came he came up to me
after and was like hey man like you know
i'm thinking you know i like this like
nft thing we're gonna make a marketplace
for things like cryptokitties and i was
like
dude
really you know like what are you doing
with your life this
nfts are dumb that was like that's never
gonna you know happen again but you know
crypto has a way of like when there's a
really interesting concept which i think
nfts were right uh it kind of plays dead
for a while and then people realize it
it comes back it gets down and that's
that's happening you know look many
things
yeah absolutely um and so uh you know so
from my standpoint obviously we're doing
a lot of fun stuff we have actually just
today we rolled out a referral program
that any one of the apps can use uh you
know where if you someone can share your
link they get 25 you get like five
dollars or something uh and so you know
that's the first money we've invested in
growing the user base uh and i think
that's gonna do well but i really think
a big part of it is you know
when you have a really good concept
which i think creator coins alone are
interesting not to even mention like
diamonds and stuff uh sometimes just
take some time for the market to figure
it out uh but yeah i think the initial
hype kind of to me showed me okay this
is this is something that you know once
people maybe get a little bit bored of
nfts they're going to look at the next
thing and this is just going to be
waiting you know so
i don't know obviously not it's all five
whatever the five percent like sean said
i love that but uh that's my you know
that's kind of my view on that's awesome
man
well listen i appreciate you coming on
uh
i think you did great and i think that
for people who uh who like trying new
stuff they should go check it out so
what's the best starting point for them
now so is it is it big clout still or
yeah well in six months it might change
but right now diamond app.com is awesome
uh it you know the developers basically
wanted to make it a 10x of bitcloud and
i think they achieved it um so that's
great uh and then if you like nfts
specifically polygram.cc is a really
awesome place to browse the nfts if you
if you're into that uh it's just a great
great way to look at them
but yeah man thanks for having me i mean
this is incredible like you guys i
like i said i'm i'm a little bit like
afraid of how well you explained it and
how much better it was than me but um
yeah i got to work on that i guess just
send people like this like a clip or
something we have uh jonathan on the
length
it's okay when you were in college
when you were in college like mining
bitcoin i was just uh you know sitting
there trying to i have no skill so i'm
just sitting there trying to convince
people to buy you know like random like
objects in my room and so you know you
get good at what you get good at you got
good at something that was extremely
valuable yeah it's something i got good
at this other thing like explaining more
for you i just
i know i know i i know like this man
this crazy bet that i'm making on you
but something tells me you're gonna be
okay
all right dude i mean look the the
upside of all this is that if diesel
works
it helps a lot of people man and
honestly not even diesel if anyone
figures out decentralized social and if
we helped in that like really like my my
mentality is if we instigated something
really good we've done a good thing for
the world and i sleep very well at night
knowing that no matter what happens like
pushing this forward
you know uh is has helped you know well
let me ask you one one other thing i've
always wondered which is you had all
these big people invest in
buying buying the currency before you
guys launched and then you launched and
they didn't all use it like
where are they
what's up with that did you hit them up
and you're like hey
brother it would be nice if you're the
number one or two person on the network
you own the coin you invest in this
before we launched can you go like you
know use the thing like or did you not
pull that card what's up with that that
must have no no that's actually mostly
me uh so we have a lot of people who are
like really big names not just in vc but
also like in hollywood and all that
stuff who who bought diesel um and they
asked me like natter like is now the
time like to really like bring this in
and like do it uh and i just didn't feel
like bitcoin was quite there yet uh now
uh with diamond and polygram i mean i
think now you know i i think it's a bit
different but it was mostly me kind of
because i don't want them to join
bring all their users and then people
are kind of like this isn't good enough
this looks weird and we lose like half
of them right out the gate right so
you know like like i said we're playing
the long game here um so the longer we
wait to really bring in the big people
and tell them hey now is the time uh i
think the better it's going to be and
the more users will have so uh but we're
we're there i think with diamond uh so
you'll probably start seeing uh some of
the bigger people using it and well
thanks for uh doing this we're like yeah
our schedule got all screwed up sean was
late because his house is flooding and
we were we were tinkering with the
timing and you overstayed with us and we
really appreciate that so you've been
very generous with your time
um
this is badass man
awesome
yeah this was fun good to meet you where
should people uh find follow you what's
your so are you still under diamond
hands are yeah at natter now uh you can
follow diamond hands and natter diamond
hands is gonna still gonna do some fun
stuff but uh natter is where i post from
so
yeah awesome all right all right thank
you so much for coming incredible just
incredible
[Music]
you